foreign
[Music]
hello guys how you doing man I'm just
chilling you know we're having a good
time and I wanted to just before we uh
get going here you know before we get
going and before we say you know welcome
to the you know how we do it
just take a take it in dude Breathe In
Breathe In Breathe Out Breathe In
Breathe Out breathe in breathing doesn't
he do that keep on breathing in you're
gonna die but um yeah dude I just wanted
to say you know I'm grateful for you
guys and uh
Let's uh let's just have a good time on
this podcast dude so here we go ladies
and gentlemen welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
Breathe In Breathe Out actually dude I'm
good kind of a good singer honestly
Breathe In Breathe Out breathe in
breathing oh whatever
oh it just got me it just got me Odell
um you guys uh it's it it's it it's it
it's rip one we're almost on the 300th
episode how about that man how about
that man the 300th episode are you crazy
dude we're in my Studios right now we
got the door open we let the air come in
because it's getting hot in the house
you know I got some construction going
on I don't even have the fan on a lot of
workers and all that [__] but they're
gonna hear this podcast dude they're on
a break right now so it's all good uh
and it's been raining in L.A it's
raining in L.A um what happens is it's
too much raining in LA and it's all good
and we keep thinking it's going to stop
and it's all good and it stops and then
it starts again and then we have it rain
on Monday and then it stops again and
it's all good now here look we're not a
weather podcast so we not going to talk
about the weather too much but it's
enough dude okay the street I live in
it's a you know it's like white water
after
rapid water white water rafting whatever
the [__] they call it I don't know can't
really say that it says we can't say
that I can't say Russell Wilson together
Russell Wilson I got it now all right
um but yeah dude
um
I uh I will be in
Louisiana I will be in Louisiana I will
be in Texas uh near Houston so go if
you're in Houston dude I'm playing
Sugarland look because I wanted the date
and Houston was all booked up and
everyone's like bitching and moaning
about they're not wanting to go to
Sugarland it's 15 miles away from
Houston go I'm going 2 000 miles you
could go 15.
um and then I will be in San Antonio
Texas
um San Antonio may be sold out by the
time this is going uh up this podcast
but Sugarland has tickets left because
that place is enormous
um yeah we're loving it what's Sugarland
sugarland's a cool name for apparently
it's a rich area which we love that we
love that dude we absolutely love rich
areas not a lot of crime so um yeah dude
but we have uh we have a good time we're
here on the podcast rip roaring
um we got uh we got a lot of stuff going
on uh and um and that's all
I uh uh subscribe and like to this super
good Channel
um we need the subscribers they're
Shadow banding us we know for a fact we
know for Rebecca we can't spread
misinformation but we know for a fact
okay I know and they can say this is
misinformation but it's not
misinformation I'm basically you know
who a-l-e-x j-o-n-e-z-e-e-s nosy but I
say it because I spell it out because I
feel like if I say it I'm gonna get
Shadow bam but it's all good dude we
keep it real you know what honestly I
only want the people who want to listen
to this podcast listen to this podcast
okay so it doesn't really even
technically matter
but um I flew back from I'm here for
like two days I flew back from
let's see where was I wow oh Lakeland
Daytona
and the other one was Jacksonville now
cesspools you do the math I don't think
that the accessibles I like the first
time I did Jacksonville thought it was a
cesspool stayed at the Ramada Inn got a
twin at the Ramada Inn
um got a twin at the Ramada Inn
and um
and uh didn't like it
this Jacksonville show well I said
Jacksonville like a like a Mexican like
a Mexican guy
um hey you play Jacksonville
um will you drive down with the Chevy
um
you're trying to live vicariously to me
um so
Aunt Vivian
um so yeah so
uh did Jacksonville but I flew back and
I'll talk about the shows a little bit
but I flew back and uh
you know I was in the in the seat right
fifth row last to First Class all good
fifth row relaxing
guy goes next to me
first of all we took off
plane was a little bumpy not really but
the captain came on he was just like
you know you hear that thing boom
all right well we're gonna actually have
um
we're gonna I've told the uh well ladies
and gentlemen I've told the flight
attendants to take their seats can be a
little bit bumpy here
um so until further notice we're gonna
keep everyone in their seats
so I'm like all right cool I'm gonna
keep everyone in our seats uh you're
gonna be able to build a little choppy
they would say chop it a little choppy
here and
it's a little choppy so we're gonna do
is we're gonna just take it out you know
we'll get that drink service out to you
no longer and they always say they're
like so you know like
just casual about it and it's like dude
we're three we're 30 000 feet in the air
and just beep a little bit more like
this is how it should be boom hey ladies
and gentlemen what's up sorry uh listen
so we're in the air and I know it's so
annoying uh we're gonna get these drinks
out to you soon but we gotta but they
don't they're just like
I don't know look you know I'm getting
uh getting an OTP HJ Pilots copilot's a
female I um she's rubbing my frenulum
too so uh look uh oh my that feels
Mighty so we are uh what was it
sweetheart
right
um we're going to uh go to what was it
right oh yeah it's choppy uh we're gonna
tell it if flight times to take his
seats for a little bit and it's all good
um but we're gonna get those drinks and
uh food out to you
whenever we hold on one second no
ah here we go yeah get that get me that
thank you
there we go here throw that out uh we're
gonna get uh you that stuff in a little
bit so just uh we'll turn on the thing
if you remember all right
and it's just like be more present
flight attendant guy right or a pilot
Guy and um
so now the belt's on the the the light
on for the for the seat belt is on for
like weight it's just too long it's not
even choppy anymore as they say and I
gotta I gotta let it go
I gotta let it go let it go
and I got I gotta stand upright and I
Gotta Be You Know
in the with the in the in the uh little
potty area the bathroom with my my neck
cocked gotta get my neck caught right so
um so but I'm in one seat you know so
I'm like to the guy I'm like looking
around and I mean he's like what's going
on and I I the guy next to me which I
just I just never want to talk to the
people on the I'm on the plane with
right and it's I don't I don't
this I don't hate them for talking
because I get you gotta talk with people
when you're sitting next to them and
that's fine but when it happens I'm
always just like all right I guess it's
gonna be one of those things and that's
I gotta deal with it
so I said nah I gotta go to the bathroom
but they got the seatbelt thing on
because you know me dude Johnny plays by
the rules and I'm serious dude you make
up a rule I do the rule I do the rule
and then
if it just so like if I gotta piss if I
gotta go TT on my pants I do it and then
that's on you dude
but the guy next to me that it was about
60. looks at me or maybe 60 and he says
Ah just get up and go uh people people
do it all the time
and he says that
now
I didn't hear it when he said it I heard
it a few seconds afterwards because when
he said it
all I instead of hearing anything I
smelled
dead bodies
[Music]
his breath dude it was
a dead body breath okay it was like he
was storing
it was like he had a mortuary behind his
lips
I go
I had the same reaction as I would
like you wouldn't have been able to tell
the difference
just outside like inside I was going
through many different things than than
this situation but if I see like a woman
with a body that's amazing or this guy's
smell this guy's breath same reaction
you would notice it in me the same thing
I went oh
same reaction inside different things
are happening but outside you could you
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
oh
well this is a this is a
this is a the phenomenon right
let's go down behind those teeth bud
you got some toe tags in there
Scout
who lives in your mouth John Doe
what's going on dude
let me reach in there pull out a few toe
tags skull skoda dude amen what'd you
eat a live rabbit
so I mean this guy's breath it it was
like you'd think oh that that's what
morbius's breath would smell like
he's been feasting on necks all day and
and I go oh and I say all right yeah I
guess so I couldn't shake it dude when
someone's breath smells bad
I can't I can't take it
that stays with me do you know what it
is
assault
right like I have a little bit of PTSD
about someone's if it's that bad I have
pts PTSD about it
I mean I would say for like oh less than
an hour
I can't get it out of my head and the
flight was five and a half hours and I'm
like all right well I'm not gonna talk I
can't talk to this guy right if he's
gonna just open up and then
right
so I turned the arrow I did a little you
know the nipple up on the top I turned
the air off the little bit chest thing
so no
floaty smells would come to me
and I go pee I sit down and do it I
fight was five hours
just when my PTSD was about to stop with
the with the with the toe tag breath
just when that was about to happen
uh
uh again I would just be sitting like I
watched movies and I would just be
sitting and all of a sudden I'd go oh
and I'd look over and I'd realize that
his mouth was open for a little bit oh
it was
so bad dude
it was so bad and it was happening so
much I thought it was me
it wasn't because I put in mints I even
I was like I know it's not me just for
[__] I'm gonna put in mints I put in
mints still happen dude
I couldn't believe it don't eat toe tax
man it was you know how people have that
lip tattoo where it says like you know
they'll do like this and it'll be like
[__] or they'll do like this and they'll
be like whatever it should he should
have done like this and he said Mortuary
um
dude it was so bad dude it happened
probably happened 12 times where I was
just sitting there minding my own
business and then all of a sudden
assault and I go oh and I look over
60 year old I'm trying to watch the
[__] 2012 version of Total Recall and
this guy's making it you know it's like
dude I can't even watch the 2012 version
of total Rico for the second time and
enjoy it because this guy's got to open
his mouth
and give me the [__] business dude
who would have thought that that's the
kind of guy the face he had too when his
breath came out I go who would have
thought a guy like you
you just look regular dude alas here we
are
um yeah it ruined my whole flight
experience so I watched Total Recall and
that's so bad that movie the new one
um level love the people in it love
Colin Farrell love Jessica Biel love
Kate Beckinsale
um and the other guy from um I always
forget his name from uh man that sucks
too because I know him
ah I'm an [__] Aaron Paul and
Brian Cranston He's the bad guy he
worked for you know like literally like
three days on it and was in the last
third of the movie anytime a big star is
in the last start of the movie he worked
three days and crammed it all in and
made one million dollars
um
you know or you know what it's like
those [__] uh Paul Giamatti uh
Verizon commercials or whatever the ATT
ones dude when you see Paul Giamatti I
go get that bag Paul Giamatti playing
Scrooge he's like oh I can't find
service I'm like get that [__]
bag dude
would they pay you for [__] three
commercials and and you just dressed up
like Scrooge and you shot it all in four
hours all three would they pay you two
three million dollars just get that back
and it's so sad in a way but also it's
not get that back get that back
always maximize the most money you can
possibly get at any time when you're
working yes that's the rule that's why I
love Tupac dude if you ain't needed for
the money man what's your [__]
purpose that was one of the Outlaws but
you know it was on Tupac songs
talk about exhibit
um
yeah dude
mob you know what I mean
um
dude it's a crash dude to be to say
money over [__] rappers get away with
everything dude
everything
a rapper could be legitimately like
he could come up from underground
and break the Earth and be like hello I
am Beelzebub
and with wings flying and you'd be like
yeah but he's got tight bars though I
don't understand
um I don't know so uh so yeah so what
was I just talking about I don't
remember just I know I talked about the
breath thing and then also the other
thing but I've been because I've been
back on my Gabapentin dude so we're
gonna have we're gonna have that word
recall problems we're gonna have them
word recall problems but it's all good
uh appreciate you guys listening to this
podcast like And subscribe we'd love it
it really helps us out leave a comment
dude [__] up that algorithm leave a
comment put that Bell notification on
too
um you know what I don't give a [__] man
honestly don't do it do it or don't I
don't give a [__] man I gotta keep it
real I gotta keep it real man they say
say they say do that it'll help I don't
give a [__] man we got the OG
[__] the we did the El the
Lakeland show
absolutely man probably one of the best
uh sets of the tour did the Daytona show
and let me tell you something dude
I had a few tickets to sell in Daytona
day of and just the day of I sold so
many tickets I don't know what the [__]
was going on and that was it somebody
just it was like a a a little boy ran
out and just goes Delia's in town
Delia's in town running down the streets
Delia's in town and ding ding ding ding
Delia's in town and then do we pack that
[__] out that sold out and then we did
Jacksonville and oh my oh my God it's
the anchor
oh it's the anchor isn't it it's the
anchor for the whole weekend off for
[__] sake isn't it it's the anchor for
for the whole weekend isn't it because
Lakeland is in between Daytona and
Orlando oh where is it and Daytona is
kind of a ah it's got the races going
but what is the place that's got six big
billions six big buildings and they
think that it's just a real City because
it's got one uh Hard Rock Hotel oh for
[__] sake and then Jacksonville's a
yanker right because it's got because
it's got the Jaguars and it's got a city
and okay it's all good but dude
and Oliver in all honesty every city was
the anchor dude I'll tell you what I'll
tell you what
we had a great time and Florida North
Florida you changed my perception of
North Florida thank you very much you
guys came out there weren't many Florida
the north of Florida is always kind of
like a woo place to perform where they
just scream out dude there was one war
and it was in Daytona couldn't believe
it and I said yo you got to stop wooing
I'm not the Jaguars no more Woos
you know
I didn't really have a chip chip on my
shoulder about it
I will say one thing that her that
therapy has helped me with is my overall
uh quick to anger
and I feel my anger sometimes and you
got to realize that the anger isn't
always the emotion that is the Primary
Emotion it's always the [__] one that
men go to right because they're either
[__] you know scared sad insecure no
no no no no no no all the [__] no no
no no no no no no no no no no no anger
is what comes out but that's not what it
is right you open the list and you go
and then we go [__] it I'll just go to
anger
um and so I was feeling my anger on
Sunday but uh but we got through it but
my my fans hold me down dude
you guys hold me [__] down
um
and we appreciate you and that's why
it's a cult
um but yeah dude uh the the Lakewood
show is awesome the the [__] um
actually the Lakeland show was the one
that uh I wanted to
you know uh look at so I have my buddy
put the camera thing on
ah whatever dude
doesn't matter
dude I go to I was at the the air
airport
when we landed in in Lake in uh wherever
the [__] we landed we landed in Tampa I
think
I get there my crew's going to the
bathroom so I go to Starbucks so I go
get a water
and this lady I was working at the
Starbucks you know they have them in the
airport every few feet and she was had
she had like it was like one of those
Standalone ones like that wasn't in the
wall that was like outside of the wall
you know it was like not like it was in
the middle of a terminal just like a
standalone Starbucks like in in in the
[__] near the gate
and I was like I need a water I want to
go get a water and the lady behind the
cash register who was doing something
else right she was like she was doing
something else like uh stop stalking
something she's like oh I didn't even
recognize you there and I say oh yeah
all good and she says and it's you and I
said yeah
you know gotta be somewhere that's my
thing when I say I finally figured out
what to say people say hey look Chris
Leah and I say gotta be somewhere
because I do and you just happen to be
here as a matter of fact it's weird as
[__] for you to be here too dude and
we're both meeting two Souls and uh
and she says I didn't even recognize you
there I said oh okay all good
goes back to do her thing a little bit
I'll be right with you doing her thing
so say okay
um then she turns back around and she
says it's good to see you man
it's good to see you out here again and
I said okay well thanks I appreciate
that now I don't know what she's talking
about yes I have landed in Tampa before
maybe she's a fan maybe she knows I tour
and I haven't been to Tampa in a long
time or maybe she's just talking about
because I took a little bit of a Hiatus
and then came back I don't know what
she's talking about okay nonetheless
she's talking to me and she's being very
friendly and that's awesome so I say
that's great thank you very much
a few maybe a minute goes by just appear
right there with you washing her hands
she says is that it is that all you want
do you want your espresso over ice and I
say oh wow this woman is a big fan you
know what your boy gets
I mean you know what I mean if you had a
crystalia trivia what is his coffee
order would be one of the questions and
if you nail down ice iced espresso I'll
tell you what you're a bigger fan than
somebody who would say iced Americano
because that's what I used to get but
then he graduated to some hardest [__]
so I go about this lady not only
is a fan she's an up-to-date fan
so I say uh you know what I'm not gonna
get that I just actually need a bottle
of water thank you very much it's pretty
it's pretty late and you know I've been
trying to curb my coffee right
and she says great
ringing up the water and then she says
to me
how were those cupcakes that you got
commissioned from me
and I say
oh
oh this was a waste this whole thing
she says how were those cupcakes you got
commissioned so now I'm in this spot
where I think well [__]
I either gotta come clean
or
lie
also is she crazy or what's going on
here
so she says how are those cupcakes that
got com that you got commissioned from
me
and I was like oh and I felt so many
different emotions I was like this lady
has a Starbucks job and she's also
making cupcakes for people
and who the [__] did she think I am
and also
I know that you're not supposed to judge
a book by his cover but do I look like a
guy that gets cupcake commissions
like am I like a guy that's like oh you
maybe I do maybe I look like a guy
that's like you do you do do that oh I
gotta get some
foreign
you do another job even though I'm at
this job you do another job and that's
the thing you do well let me hire those
services like never would I ever be a
guy who walks in to establish an
establishment for a certain thing and
then purchase their side job [__] you
know
that's weird to me
so
I she says did you get your your
cupcakes commission for me and I I just
go like this because here's the other
thing too in rehab they say rigorous
honesty dude you gotta be telling the
truth about everything
or else you ain't [__] so I now in my
head I gotta be like well if that's what
they mean do they mean that for this or
this is just like I don't even know this
person so I'm like I gotta be like oh
it's actually not I thought maybe you
recognized me because I'm a community I
gotta do all this [__] I'm a comedian
and I don't really know what you talk
about the cupcake here's the deal what
if I say that and she's like no you got
cupcakes commission and I'm just like oh
I'm dealing with a [__] lunatic with
a job
because lunatics have jobs out there by
the way
you know we always think of lunatics as
just like walking around on the street
smelling bad talking about the
government but dude there's Luna there's
high functioning lunatics and this lady
could be one of those so I I'm like she
says very quickly I do all these
thoughts in my head she says how are the
kind of cakes that you that you could
that you got commissioned from me and I
say well they were great
foreign
and now I'm nervous because I'm like I
hope that this ends before she realizes
I'm the [__] absolute you know what I
mean one of the top dog comedians dude
I hope that she realizes this before I'm
some dude that [__] sells out copious
theaters dude I hope she realizes before
she can place me in one of my many TVs
appearance I'm like you know
so I get the water and I leave and then
I tell Lulu about it and she and she's
like
laughing so I didn't you know
I should have I should have maybe been
honest with her but I don't even know
for for all I know I don't I don't know
where that honestly because I don't know
where that I don't owe her that because
maybe she's just a crazy person so it's
all good we figured it out thank you we
figured it out on this podcast I
appreciate you guys I really do
appreciate you guys thank you
um
yeah
there's some [__] crazy [__]
at coffee shops huh like just straight
up I go there's a guy a coffee shop I go
to and there's a guy with Tourette
Syndrome he's in there and one of it's
pretty alarming because I kind of like
now I know but the first few times I
went there I'm like is this guy just
like what is he because a lot of it
would be like you know he would do that
I'm just like oh that's [__]
completely disgusting don't get whatever
you get usually here you know it's
making you do that sir
and then I realized he was saying stuff
like not even really necessarily bad
words that's the other thing too like it
would be really dope to have uh
Tourette's but if it will it would be
horrible to have Tourette syndrome and
honestly I kind of feel like I a little
bit understand Tourette Syndrome because
I think that's what OCD is like a cousin
of Tourette Syndrome it really is
because like I don't have to do that
[__] again but I have to do this [__]
again so kind of that's what I would I
kind of understand when that when
somebody's like ah but I gotta do it
Monica Lewinsky you know what I mean or
whatever the [__]
I gotta do it
you know
I gotta do it and they're just like uh
Indians are the problems whatever the
[__] right and so
um
so now I'm I I realize he has threat
syndrome but do I go to this coffee shop
man and he's always there and and here's
the thing it's a little disconcerting in
the beginning but now I go there and I
love that the guy's always there doing
his [__] thing and the people
at the coffee shop don't give a [__]
about it I love the acceptance that they
have for them that dude I love it right
I just love it the dude's sitting there
he's about 60 something years old and
he's yelling out [__] and he's not you
know it's not horrible stuff because
that's the other thing too if you have
Tourette Syndrome you want the stuff
where you're not yelling out you know
right
like why can't you just be one of the
why don't it's always something real bad
it's never like big fan of NASCAR or
whatever the [__]
how about a turkey sandwich it's never
that that would be [__] ill as [__]
that's the Tourette's I want but um
so he's doing that and and and that
coffee shop so so just because that
guy's doing that all the time when I'm
there the coffee shop is obviously lit
and I'm not gonna tell you what coffee
shop it is because I want to go and I
don't want people people bugging me when
I'm there anyway they want pictures or
whatever what can I say he sells a
copious theaters
but
um
yeah dude so the coffee shop is lit
they always ask me if I wanted for that
if I have the app and it's like I don't
want the app I just let me [__] do it
you know and so today I go and there was
a [__] woman there a lady there on
full on on a full on Zoom meeting
on her computer
check this out dude
no headphones
[Music]
no
headphones dude just on it first of all
who goes on a zoom meeting with no
headphones
even at home dude
don't you feel exposed
put them headphones on lady
dude she's got no I can't believe I do
the things
so I walk in and first of all I hear
y'all now and I'm like what what is she
oh she must be watching a quick video
because I'll tell you this much you
watch a quick video in public no
headphones I'm good
you want to watch a quick video if it's
30 seconds I'm good maybe that's what
this lady is doing I look over she looks
like a regular lady nice looking regular
ladies so I'm like hey regular lady Go
On
and then I realized
hold up
it's not stopping I'm in line with my
thing you know
and I look over and I try to see her
screen because dude if you're gonna have
this and that's what and I just so I was
just
I look at a scoop
six boxes of people
six boxes of people none of them have
had cell phones on either
so I'm like what is this company
topsy-turvy Limited
[Laughter]
what is this company dude
Topsy Turvy law practices
topsy-turvy LLC dude
so uh and now I'm I'm like this is very
interesting in the meantime the guys in
the back just like oh oh
and then uh and then I know I'm
listening and she's we just want to go
over some of the discrepancies with the
when you go line by line and the ladies
just
to her computer kind of RR every coffee
shop is so lit
show me the coffee shop where there's
not a lit person in 30 minutes in there
for 30 minutes dude if you're at a
coffee shop for 30 minutes no lit person
you are in the middle of bum [__]
nowhere
you're not in a lit coffee shop dude
you're not in one in the city in the
city dude
and then uh no [__] I left the the
coffee shop and and and and I got hit
with the dude's breath again I'm not
lying I thought it was a PTSD moment and
there was a homeless guy out there like
and I felt bad and I was like that is
what that guy's breath smell like
so
and then I went to my car and Noble and
for real there were there was a couple
in their back seat just getting it on
and I saw through their front windshield
and I was just like this is the most lit
coffee shop that there has ever been in
the world
God bless these people just doing what
the [__] they want we all need to strive
to be a little bit more like that now
here's the deal it affects everybody
right like you're you're on a zoom
meeting in public and there's a and we
just need to go over line by line in the
discrepancies
is the thing because what because I
here's the thing I was talking to Hans
in Germany
and he was just wondering about the
discrepancies on line five
and you're and then so it's like it
affects us
but this lady man I was sitting there
the whole time I sat there 30 minutes 40
minutes at the coffee shop and she was
just on Zoom I wish I could have joined
the meeting
um
so yeah
I I the audacity of people but also we
need to live to strive to be more like
that but do we you know because then I
go back on it and I'm like but do we
because do we because honestly does it
really affect maybe it affects people I
don't know dude I go back and forth on
it but I'm just growing and changing I'm
a person you know
so I'm in Jacksonville we went so we
were in Daytona
we were first of all the time religion
put us up in a resort 30 minutes away
from Daytona I was like what am I
retired
so my manager was like all right we're
gonna [__] actually you want to leave
the night tonight instead and I said
yeah let's just go to Jacksonville and
then wake up in Jacksonville tomorrow so
okay I'll get this printer van to come
get us at the show and I go bet I don't
even say that
files done so
uh the guy picks us up from the show we
go to Jacksonville and David is already
you know David Sullivan my friend he's
done the podcast before he's the only
non-family member member I've had on the
podcast and he's just already like the
thing about David is he'll just come he
comes you watch some of the tour reports
he's on go watch him go on the Chris Lea
official Channel and he comes in hottest
like dude the guy talk the guy doesn't
he's a great look he's a great guy a
down homie Saul to the Earth genuine
generous
phenomenal loving guy one of my true
best friends and you would be lucky if
this guy spent any time around you
but here's the thing
all of that time
he's talking
okay
so that's fine for maybe a normal person
but for me
when you're talking too much and it's
before one
in my head
Bombs over a Baghdad you know what I
mean it's just like too much also here's
the thing he's the kind of guy who asks
a question and then lets it sit a little
bit and then asks more about the
question dude fire them all off
immediately Farm all off let's get
through it
we're on the Sprinter van watching
[__] Dr pimple popper
which is a show where like by the way
what
I watched Dr pimple popper I go like
this but where are the pimples dude
they're like cutting out baseballs
a guy will show up with like a shark fin
on the back of his neck and he'll be
like yeah I've had it for 30 years I
just I don't know it's like a guy why
weren't you
taking I have 11 bumps on my head that
the size of either a golf ball or a
softball and I've had them on for 25
years and it's like hey but guy
life though
didn't you ever wanna do anything
what about
going outside
so
we're watching the [__] Dr pimple
popper and we're on the it's in the
Sprinter van and yes I have TV on my
Sprinter van
okay and we're watching Hulu which is
where Dr pimple popper is on the thing
and I put on Hulu and he goes like this
hey man can you can we get the game oh
no and I was like No And he says because
why because you don't want to and I was
like no because you need a subscription
to get the game and this Sprinter
doesn't have a subscription to Hulu
he says oh all right
there you go normal person goes like
this
I wash my hands of that conversation
because it's over
so I turned on Dr pimple popper and
under that it says what's on TV and he
says hey man what sound are there
and it says Chiefs versus or whoever the
[__] they're playing and I said yeah
that tells what else is on TV and he
said I thought you said can't watch the
football things and I was like you can't
because we don't have a subscription
well you remember I said that
and he said okay man but I'm just saying
they're down there oh cool thank you for
telling me that
so now we're watching Dr pimple popper
and he says and a commercial happens on
Dr Pepper and he says hey man fast
forward that and I said well
do first of all do extra thinking right
you got the guy's showing up at the door
the party's going on inside and he's
saying brought the casserole giving you
the casserole and then just watching the
party from the inside
you brought the casserole come on in and
have some
but this guy is just at the door of this
conversation and goes like this
no that's it
how come you don't really fast forward
that
so I say well you know how we can't
watch the game because we don't have a
subscription here
we actually can't now this is the extra
thinking part if you were to just be a
regular human for a second you can't
also you can't watch yeah the pers
obviously the subscription is making so
you don't have to watch the commercials
give us
cave fast forward two commercials right
and he says all right oh okay
and I just I feel them dude we're
watching the commercials and I'm just
feeling them and like two commercials
later he says
you fast forwarded it earlier
and I'm just like
oh dude
but it was during the show part wasn't
it
and he says so just fast forward this
part
and I and I'm like are we really doing
this dude because this is a step closer
to fisticuffs
like you're you're not doing extra
you're not doing it you're just come on
in dude come on into the party have some
of this dip
drink some of this punch
eat some of the casserole you brought
dance
but he's just
I don't do that
so I'm like you can't fast forward the
commercials remember that and he says
well you just fast forwarded already and
I said yeah the part of the show and he
says all right
and then he says
because it was the episode that we had
watched in the uh hotel room and he
wanted to show somebody part of it and
he said well you should fast forward to
the part
oh he said he says I said so I no I'm
sorry so I fast forwarded to the part
that we want to see at the end with the
guy getting the thing cut out of his
neck and he says man
and I'm like yeah and he says you just
fast forwarded it and I said I fast
forward the show part and he said well
then why but you fast forward past all
the commercials and I said no I didn't
do it watch watch what happens now
the commercials come on and I say you
got to watch the commercials if you fast
forward this [__] because those are the
ads you can't fast forward the
commercials
and I wanted that's what I imagined you
know what I mean and he says so now we
got to watch all the commercials on the
TV that we skipped and I said dude
we finally got to the part where I don't
know
but it doesn't matter
so I'm like and I'm like I gotta sit
with this [__]
just like why all the who am I Chris
Hulu
I don't know just [__] can we I'm all
steaming I just want to watch the guys
back of the naked [__] I want to see
his bumps removed
and so that's what he's like right
so we're watching Dr pimple popper we
show everyone everybody's flipping out
because the guy's getting his neck sawed
off or whatever
so we get to Jacksonville we go to sleep
whatever the [__] and then it's like
the next day he wakes up and it's and
and I have a text from him in the text
group
and it said no [__] it says this
I reserved the court at 12 30. I'm going
to get paddles now meet at the court
y'all
it's 11 something and he says meet at
12th and I and now I'm offended because
you don't know me
first of all
huh
second of all
don't put money down on anything
expecting me I'm gonna be there
okay
second of all
12 30.
I wake up at 12.
paddles
you want me moving around
within 30 minutes dude I can't even talk
to you until three
so I'm looking at the rest of the text
and Denny and Lulu are like oh man
already oh what and I go and I say hey
we gotta not not do this I gotta get
coffee I'm getting coffee Denny and Lulu
like yeah you get coffee
and then I'm like what is this and I
realize it's a paddle ball or no
pickleball
ah [__] you know there's so many of
them
there's so many different sizes of
paddles and balls and heaviness of balls
and the courts are different sizes and
then there's even a table one like a
ping pong it's like figure out the good
one and then that's it
it's in between somewhere tennis and
ping pong which it might be pickleball
it may be compatible I don't know I used
to play Oh I played all of them
but it's like if we figured it out great
but we should have already figured it
out so now this pickleball is all the
rage and people are like oh they love
how Emma whoever did the Twilight [__]
is into it or not not her no the one who
did the one who played the in the uh uh
The Wizard movie uh Harry Potter who's
that one
Emma Watson
she's like uh you look at a pickleball
hashtag and it's like every picture is
of Emma Watson doing the thing
and so
I'm like you want to play Pickleball and
I just go I've got to get a coffee dude
this is just this is literally and you
want me to for how by the way here's the
thing you don't play sports where you
need to get equipment for for less than
an hour it's like you got to play for at
least an hour but most of the time way
more than that so I'm like I also have
to do a show tonight
I'm doing 70 minutes for 2 800 people
your boy's got to be ready
okay and here's the other thing I don't
wake up and not take a shower
I wake up and I take a shower so this
means I gotta take two showers so anyway
this is all the stuff that's going on in
my mind and I said we got to get a
coffee so we do we went and we did a
[__] one Sip Coffee review it's over
on the crystally official Channel we
went to side side somewhere
some coffee it was it was good
um so go check that out but um
I might not be up yet but so we get to
coffee and David
no we go in the lobby to meet get the
coffee without David because we don't
know where the [__] he is he's M.I.A
doing something pickleball mission
it's like noon something it's like maybe
12 30 when the courts were already
reserved and David comes walking in
because we're waiting for everyone to go
to get the coffee wait for the Uber
David comes walking in with a sack dude
with like not a a bag it's like a sack
with handles coming out of it four of
them so now I'm like oh were you at the
courts and he's like yeah man for like
20 minutes and I said oh oh so it was
like one right already is it really and
he said yep I said well uh what were you
doing there he said I don't know man
everyone already had
players with each other so I was just
kind of playing by myself and I said I I
was like you just went to the pickleball
courts hoping for the best with four
paddles like what the [__]
what is this White Men Can't Jump like
this is not you didn't go to the [__]
it's not basketball dude
so he comes back and I'm like
you were just there yeah I was just
hitting back and forth I don't know just
kind of Smashing it I'm like oh dude
you're a loser man you're 45 doing this
and so I'm like well we gotta go get a
coffee so we go get a coffee and he's
got the [__] sack of pickleball uh
paddles
we get to the coffee place we're
drinking the coffee sitting down and
we're eating the [__]
sandwiches and David's just like this
this is what David's doing he's looking
at his phone he's going like this
well I'll be damned and I was like what
and he said
the pickleball court is literally across
the street and I
and I in my head I'm like who Hoodwinked
me who was it because Sam my camera guy
was saying that this was the coffee shop
that we could go to
did David have it like a sidebar
discussion with him and said we should
go to this place so now I'd be close to
because the only way I'm going to do the
pickleball shits is if
I am right there
because I'm I'm in I'm in my [__]
Yeezys I'm in like I don't wanna I'm not
ready
my manager's in jeans and [__] Keds
or whatever the hell he wears on his
feet I think they're Vans or Keds
and like so we go over there and he got
me dude I played I played pickleball for
the they've been trying to get me to
play [__] pickleball and dude I won
my first game I won two games dude so
I'm [__]
I don't know man I'm a force to be
reckoned with dude swear to God
[Music]
and uh
you know it was a good time and then
that's the thing I'm talking about is we
got back in the car afterwards and then
I started to sweat after I'm done
playing like I didn't sweat when I play
because my body's like no no no no we
need it all for now and then afterwards
I just start pouring sweat and we're in
the car and he's like how are you I'm
like I'm sweating dude I'm pissed off
that now that I liked it and I had a
good time that's the curmudgeon in me
dude
I don't want to be forced to have a good
time man what the hell's wrong with me
I'm sure a lot of you identify with that
um
but yeah
yeah we have a good time dude we have a
good time on the road and then I went
home I had to take another shower I went
to the hotel I had to take another
shower and then [__] change my
clothes and then win and I did a show
and I wasn't even really that sore I
thought I was going to be sore but I
wasn't it was all good we had a good
time
um appreciate you guys coming out in
Jacksonville Daytona and Lakeland man
Lakeland was it's so funny doing the
cities that are so close to each other
because they all talk [__] about each
other I did Lakeland and I and they were
and I was talking about like others I
was going to Jackson and Daytona and
they were all like Boo and then I go to
Daytona and I said some of Jacksonville
they're like Boo and I'll go
Jacksonville and then I said something
about Lakeland and I was like and and
Daytona and they weren't saying [__] I
was like yo you know what they said
about you they were booing
and they were like what the [__] so you
go to the city they hate the city two
hours away and it's true I don't know
what the [__] that's all about there's
just this stupid Pride where you just
you have Pro you're just proud because
of the where you end up where you ended
up
you literally just have pride because
you were born somewhere it's like that
[__] old Seinfeld joke about how like
you root for the teams but really you're
just rooting for the jerseys because the
players keep changing
I don't know I think that's a Seinfeld
joke but I don't know I gotta get rid of
this black nail polish
um
dude I was at uh oh let me talk about
this I was in Hardy as a musician a
country musician a [__] it was like
it's like good country though it's like
even if you're not a country person you
kind of like it and I went to his album
release party because he invited me and
I went to the Roxy and I watched him
perform the dude kills it love Hardy he
kills it and I was there and um
young gravy was there tall drink of
water and then [__] I turn around
Machine Gun Kelly's there and he sees me
and I'm like oh what's up bro and we we
shake hands and [__] and Machine Gun
Kelly was talking about the podcast and
how
um he watches it and uh I wanted to give
a shout out to [__] Hardy young gravy
and then also Machine Gun Kelly who I
[__] love Machine Gun Kelly because
dude this guy was like you gotta bring
back the [__] misconnections and I
was like really I was like but that [__]
writes itself like he was like dude that
[__] kills me and I was like I don't
know it because I feel like that's he's
like that's the funny that's one of the
funniest things and I'm like but that
isn't even me doing it it's like these
[__] people that are just
lunatics and he was like so you got to
bring that [__] back so next episode I'm
gonna bring back the misconnections okay
okay just remind me
um again that's for Machine Gun Kelly
the guy's a tall drink of water you know
what dude I saw Machine Gun Kelly and I
whenever I see Machine Gun Kelly I'm
reminded about how [__] yeah dude
this guy's got that [__] thing that
star powered that sex appeal and I'm all
[__] gay for it whatever
so
um
yeah we stand him
and uh
and then we talked me and him and young
gravy and Hardy and [__] shout out to
Hardy check out his new album
uh it was at the raw we did it we were
at the Roxy you know I'm a country fan
Hollywood's so funny man the Hollywood
is the most insane [__] because it's
like
um
because it's like you'll just be I
forget though that like
you know when you have a little bit of
Fame you go somewhere and when there's
other people with a little bit of Fame
it's like this club that you're in and
it kind of sucks because
it's so hard to get in that club but
then when you're in it you forget that
it sucked because you're like finally
I'm accepted and now you can hang out
with like [__] you know Neil Patrick
Harris or something and it's like why do
I wanna what is even this you know am I
is this what I'm doing it for because
dude I have a family I have a son I have
a wife like what matters to me
I mean look good people are good people
whether they're famous or not but it's
like it's just like too much man it was
actually a trip to talk though about
like to Hardy and uh Michigan Kelly
uh about like my podcast it's always a
trip
it's a trip I'm very grateful
um
it's just so [__] weird man
bodyguards are crazy I don't have
bodyguards uh but if you're a musician
you obviously have to have a bodyguard
and when when when musicians show up
they're just like
hey move and you're like oh okay I'm
dude I'm a [__] comedian it's all
good man like yeah but we gotta make way
you're like okay
they're just sitting around and [__]
it's so confusing
um
I gotta get some bodyguards for real
dude you know what I gotta get some
bodyguards just for the [__] of it and
also well I do get death threats by the
way but
I gotta get some bodyguards but I'm
talking about you know people usually
have like two bodyguards at the most
your boy I'm gonna whatever ancillary
budget I have that's going for
bodyguards and I'm getting
11. I'm getting
I want to walk around with 25 bodyguards
at all the biggest dudes and like you
know people there's always like oh you
oh
people are always like the racist people
are like oh big black body no dude [__]
all that you ever seen a Croatian
you ever seen a [__] Croatian
you might as well hire a TR um a tree
with limbs to bodyguard you dude to
guard your body I will tell you no you
know what [__] all that I'm getting one
bodyguard I'm paying whatever Kevin
Costner cost
because he was in the movie no I'm
getting [__] 25 croatians to help me
they're what dude you ever seen it you
think because the big black guys are the
ones that are the ones that everyone
wants you've seen a [__] Croatian
bodyguard have you seen a Croatian
salesman you can't move them dude
I was when I used to do it Jiu Jitsu I I
quit no joke after a Croatian came in
and was like hey I would like to sign up
for classes
and I was like uh okay the guy was like
okay come on in Chris get with him dude
I had been doing it for five years
okay
let's go dude whatever his name is let's
go I put him in my guard
stay
dude
12 minutes just
that's a tree
it's a folding it's not even a folding
chair it's just a chair
you can't move them I'm getting 25
Croatian bodyguards that's what I'm
getting
little ones too
it's gonna look like you know
the [__] me I'm with the Lollipop
Guild like just just absolutely just
jumping on people's backs if they even
look at me wrong
what the [__] what's this we call him
the backpack
it doesn't matter though you're gonna be
dead in four seconds you don't need to
know that information the backpack's got
you
and he's gonna have an actual backpack
on and even littler One's Gonna Come Out
And then [__] move around the front
and just beat the punch a guy's face
while he's getting choked out
yeah you thought the yeah the Croatian
ones are the ones to get I know everyone
thinks that the big right the big black
ones but no the Croatian ones so oh
Delia's on that next level Croatian
bodyguard [__] he's like bro you oh you
thought that [__] MGK had the two
biggest bodyguards watch when Delia
comes dude croatians
um so anyway I appreciate you that's the
thing I'm going to be in I'm going to be
in Sugarland I'm going to be in New
Orleans and I'm going to be in New York
and Chicago and Rhode Island those are
my next dates I am in Austin in
Minneapolis as well I'm gearing up to
shoot my special be on the lookout for
when that's going to be dropping what
city I'm going to be doing it in
um really happy with my ACT I'm I'm I'm
I'm loving stand up again and uh I
appreciate you all coming out and
showing some love so get those tickets
at crystalia.com I'll see you soon
Louisiana I'll see you soon
um
the [__] one I said whatever whatever
it was Sugarland Houston Houston and
then uh Houston and then uh
San Antonio New York New York Rhode
Island let's at the Vets dude hey guys
that's it for the YouTube version if you
want the raw the uncut the uncensored uh
extra long version go over to
patreon.com christalia go over onto
patreon.com and you get it for only six
bucks and you also get all the other
backlogged episodes of congratulations
it's also great for gifting yes so go
get it and uh we appreciate you dude
thank you
the adventures
[Music]